[Music]
hi in a speaking exam you may be asked
to share an opinion or have a discussion
with a partner about a topic in this
video we'll have a look at how to
express your opinions and how you can
agree or disagree with someone else's
point of view let's have a look at some
phrases you can use to express your
opinions some good phrases to use for
expressing your opinion are I think I
believe I like and in my opinion for
example if you were talking to your
friend about movies you might say I
think action movies are the best you can
also express yourself with the negative
forms of these phrases I don't like
horror movies or I don't believe the
world needs any more Transformers films
are good examples of sentences to
express opinion do you want to make your
statement stronger you can use adverbs
and adjectives to do this instead of I
believe or in my opinion you can use I
strongly believe or in my honest opinion
adverbs and adjectives are useful for
showing you're serious about a topic as
well as expressing your opinion it is a
good conversation skill to ask about
other people's opinions phrases like
what do you think about and how do you
feel about our good questions to keep a
conversation going
you might ask someone what's your
opinion on climate change or use a
question after you make a statement I
think the blue jacket is the nicest what
do you think knowing how to agree and
disagree with someone else's opinion is
just as valuable as being able to
express your own opinion you can use
short statements to show you feel the
same as the speaker for example if a
friend says I think football is more fun
than tennis you could respond with I
agree or that's right or me too you can
disagree with a statement in a similar
way you could
eh that's not right I don't think that's
very good
or simply I've disagree if you have
mixed feelings on an issue you can use a
more neutral phrase for example I'm not
sure about that or i partly agree with
you it's normal to explain your opinions
as part of a discussion if your friend
says I think the learn English teens
channel is great
don't just respond with your opinion
alone use a statement to justify you
could say me too
they have amazing presenters or I agree
it's way more interesting than reading
text books for more tips on learning
English and preparing for your exam
subscribe to our Channel and visit the
learn English teens website where you'll
find loads more learning material to
help you improve your English
[Music]